à première vue il paraît clos presque
impénétrable
mais en s'approchant le visiteur
découvre un jardin où la nature semble
avoir pris le dessus au fond comme des
tableaux presque un musée aux effets de
miroir une création qui a su séduire
réflexion d'un collectionneur obtient le
premier prix
il ya une quasi unanimité ce jardin avec
ses miroirs qui reflètent des migros
jardins cachés
tout le monde a été très très
enthousiaste pour les autres prix
il ya eu des débats très sympathique
parce que beaucoup n'ont jardins sont
elles ces extraordinaires et donc dans
ce cas là on a ceux qui viennent le
monde végétal ceux qui viennent de monde
de la qui nous a dit des avis un peu
différent pour le prix du design
le collectionneur dhombres un espace
voulu comme le tarmac d'un aéroport où
seraient entreposés des fougères qu un
botaniste ne serait jamais venu chercher
en fait c'est une plante passionnante la
fougère parce qu'en fait vous avez
environ 13000 les espèces de fougères
dans le monde
là on en a que 200 bons mais c'est quand
même je pense une des plus belles
collections de fougères qu'il ya en
france qui ont été rassemblés dans cet
espace le festival des jardins est une
pépinière de talents la preuve avec le
prix palette végétale décerné à une
jeune équipe au concept nostalgique on
voulait qu'ils aient une accumulation
comme il pouvait y avoir dans les
jardins de noé
nos grands pères ou de nos arrière
grands pères même et c'est réussi parce
que tous les gens qui rentrent dans le
jardin nous ne nous disent pas qu'ils
ont la sensation d'être dans un jardin
de leur grand père ou leur arrière grand
père prix du jardin transposable celui
dont on peut s'inspirer pour chez soi à
ses suspensions climatique
enfin le coup de coeur pour six lances à
mousse comme une oasis de fraîcheur
avant l'été